welcome back to new rockstars I'm Erik
Bosse in Black Widow released a new
trailer during the Superbowl and while
on the surface it's not as
earth-shattering as scarlet witch's new
sitcoms or Loki's prison flare it does
contain some hidden clues that caught
our ear and no I'm not referring to
david harbors banshee scream ok we got
some major clues about taskmaster some
details about the timeline of this movie
and how this all connects to the events
of Avengers endgame so let us break down
everything you might have missed in this
trailer and spoiler warning in case I
predict anything too right and ruins
your life hey and thanks to privacy
dot-com for sponsoring this episode if
you sign up now a privacy calm slash new
rock stars you can get $5 today to use
on any purchase online ok let's get
started with the first half of the
trailer you don't know everything about
me the Avengers weren't my first family
okay now much of the footage here is
stuff that we have seen in past trailers
be sure to go check out our past
breakdowns of those but a few new
details to point out here
Natasha's voiceover states you don't
know everything about me
Avengers weren't my first family it's
interesting that Natasha would say this
because remember this movies apparently
set between civil war in 2016 and
infinity 1 2018 and early on and endgame
years later her words to cap directly
contradicted what she says here I just
have nothing and then I got this this is
John his family and it was always better
because of him and yeah Natasha only
emotionally equate Ian her fellow of
enters with family was so important to
work an end game it's kind of weird for
her to now say oh wait I had another
Russian family at I never talk about
those theorize in that this black widow
movie could be taking place in a
separate timeline within the Marvel
multiverse as the events of infinity
warned endgame could use this as
evidence that this is a different
antosha one that we could see live on an
MCU face for or this just means that the
events of this film will be so bitter
for Natasha that this family of Russian
spies will leave her feeling so betrayed
and alone that she will just move on in
pretend they don't exist in our history
to that which he talks to captain
endgame she really considers those
a-holes nothing to her I should also
point out that when Natasha says the
Avengers weren't like first family the
end of that sentence audio does not
match Skaar chose lips at all just
weren't my first family first
yeah we sure there's a lot in the
trailer breaking down business either
this audio is from a different scene
altogether or so totally possible
it was just recorded for promo purposes
and won't at all be in the movie and
speaking of awkward audio sting came
next there's the Lexie's weird shriek
Avengers weren't my first Emily
yogi berra I'm really enjoying the
electric music that is in these trailers
I'm wondering if this is the moment of
Lexi's rescue from Rush imprisoned by
his old family his friends because his
reaction here reminds me a lot of Thor's
surprise reunion with Hulk and Ragnarok
actually let's uh fix the shriek here
yeah better now a few visual details
with Alexi here we have talked about his
Russian Prison tattoos in previous
videos but this angle shows us more of
that ankang down linking each side of
the tower of st. Basil's Cathedral you
can make out a double-headed eagle
now this emblem is on the Russian coat
of arms it dates back to the days of the
Byzantine Empire after the fall of
Constantinople this symbol became a
general imperial icon on a soaring
predator looking out eastward and
westward it was used by Russian Czars
and an important motif in heraldry of
the house of a Romanov probably not the
same as Natasha Romanoff but it's kind
of fun connection now the double-headed
eagle was abolished by the Russian
Revolution in 1917 Soviets erasing much
of their brush and cultural ancestry but
it was restored in 1993 depending on win
alexei got that tat it could have been
an insult to his soviet KGB captors and
before i move on notice that nametag on
Alexis jacket here those letters appear
to be the Russian Cyrillic for a cove
maybe it's just his surname Shostak ov
but I don't know there's enough room on
that tag for just I just want him in a
world where red Guardian killed a fellow
prisoner and stole his jacket you know
to paralleled Natasha stealing your Lane
is best and faster stealing all the
Avengers gear like all families this
siblings steal each other's clothes
now look folks with Marvel phase 4 upon
us Disney is taking our money not just
for the theatrical releases we got to go
see but also all the Disney Plus series
that will supposedly tie-in with these
movies forcing us to subscribe to yet
another streaming service and for me the
best way to manage all of my content
subscriptions so no I don't get
overcharged accidentally is by using
privacy calm and thanks to privacy about
comprar sponsoring this breakdown
privacy lets you pay for things online
using virtual burner cards instead of
real cards that way you can protect your
identity and baking information when
you're shopping online but also you can
control the limits on the cards you
create so for example i've set up an
account for privacy and i linked to my
bank account and i created a card
specifically for my monthly netflix
subscription payment privacy will ding
you with wavy and fast precision if
someone tries to charge that card twice
or if the charge exceeds the amount you
set for it so you know if you're done
catching up on witcher on netflix
and the adventures of baby Yoda on
Disney Plus and you're honestly good
waiting until August for Falcon Winter
Soldier you can cap those subscription
payments with privacy and then the
content providers won't make you pay for
another month that you don't want it's
just taken care of for you no vendor can
overcharge beyond the limit you've set
it's simple it's fast it's really just
one click privacy also offers different
plans there's this free one where you
can create up to 12 cards a month but
also there's a pro plan where you can
get 36 cards a month and one person cash
back on your purchases there's also a
team's plan for small businesses
something for everybody there's also a
privacy Chrome extension where you can
fill out all of your card info to save
time one-click and all your details are
instantly entered just ahead to privacy
calm / new rockstars to sign up for an
account and as a special treat for my
viewers new customers will automatically
get five bucks to spend on your first
purchase for a limited time only kept
Isis free money just go to privacy comm
slash new rockstars and sign up now okay
let's move on to the second half of the
trailer at some point we all have to
choose between what the world wants you
to be
new you are okay some more new footage
here in this wreckage that we have seen
etosha standing among in pass shots
she's apparently joined by alexei molina
in yelena you could see a parachute
billowing in the background so i'm
guessing that this takes place after
that debris littered skydive sequence we
also get a new look at the exploding
structure i think they're jumping from
which looks to me like some kind of
modern architecture tower let me know
what you think this is but really the
takeaway detail of this trailer is
taskmaster a character whose identity
remains a mystery could the mirrored
movements of the character point to
molina or yelena and disguise well the
leading speculation of the moment is
that taskmaster tony masters is a
character Otzi fact Finlay will be
playing since he's really been m.i.a
from all the promo footage so far I also
have suggested recently and a theory
that you guys really need to go check
out even if you don't buy it
that taskmaster could be Natasha herself
in a plot that involves time travel
because visible and past footage have
been objects that look very much like
Pym particles and particles also appear
in the Funko pop figurines and as I have
said before the toys never lie in this
trailer taskmaster mirrors yet another
move specific to another Avenger that
Captain America shield kickflip we saw
cap do this at the end of the famous
elevator fight in Winter Soldier
taskmasters powers in the comics allow
him to use photographic reflexes to
mirror any combat move that he observes
but he was not present in that elevator
though there was security camera footage
of it as seen by Sitwell observing it
remotely and at the end of that movie
natasha leaked all of this shield
slashed Hydra servers to the public so
presumably taskmaster could have found
that footage online and learned the
shield move there but I love this easel
if you look even more closely at
taskmasters hands you can barely make
out another mirrored Avenger attack
claws on the tips of his fingers just
like the claws on Black Panthers
vibranium suit gloves literally
taskmaster must have watched all of
Peter Parker's new YouTube videos from
Civil War saw a black panther scratch
cap shield and said I want that now a
reminder that you can chat directly with
me when these trailers drop on new
rockstars official discord which lately
has been kind of my go-to for theories
and the place where I get to unleash all
my unfiltered reactions to these Marvel
updates for discord access become a
patron of new rock stars today at
patreon
complex new rock stars but you do you
think taskmaster is comment down below
with your thoughts and be sure to check
out my breakdown to the footage from the
Disney Plus teaser wanna business
outcome Winter Soldier lookie some
really good clues found there follow me
at EA boss followed new rock stars on
social media and subscribe to new rock
stars for all of our Marvel breakdowns
thanks for watching bye
[Music]